hi everybody
welcome to responsible ai from theory to
practice
my name is tracy frey and i'm the
director of product strategy and
operations
for cloud ai and industry solutions
to start us off i want to root us all in
this statement
in less than 10 years ai will be the
number one driver
of global gdp growth
this graph shows that growth through
2030
13 trillion dollars and not only that
organizations that achieve ai absorption
will be the leaders
of the global economy in that time
that growth has already started people
around the world have become
everyday ai users and soon technology
that isn't ai enabled will feel like
something is missing
think of technologies that we didn't
have 10 years ago
direct payment applications like venmo
virtual home assistance
our reliance on ai has already begun
and it will only become more pronounced
to 2012 ai results closely tracked
moore's law
with compute doubling every two years
post
2012 compute has been doubling every 3.4
months for example vision ai
has gotten more accurate and more
powerful
take a look at the error rate
progression here from 2011
to 2020. while this is undoubtedly good
news
for innovation it also requires
more care and attention from a
responsibility standpoint
a more accurate and powerful vision ai
technology
when used in a harmful way can lead to
harmful
and intentional misuse unintentional
failure modes
loss of personal privacy contributing to
severe
real-life consequences for individuals
all
at incredible speed and scale
ccs insights reports that trusting ai
systems
just like the vision ai is the biggest
barrier to adoption
moving from the lab to production for
enterprises there's a perception
that there is broadly a deficit in the
areas of ethical diligence
over these powerful technologies we hear
a lot of questions
on responsible ai once organizations
start to think about moving to
production
and responsible ai is impacting ai
adoption
and as a team we are seeing more and
more companies
come to us asking for help because they
are facing challenges
there's a lack of trust in the ai
systems themselves
and when ethical issues rise which 90
of organizations have encountered 40
of companies abandon instead of solving
for those issues
these numbers show a huge risk in not
taking responsibility into consideration
it's not possible for any technology to
be morally
or values neutral values are
interpolated at every stage of ai
development
and each technology is developed in
order to do something
which expresses a value decision
that reveals a huge barrier to ai
adoption
and it's a key driver
why one study found these reasons for
ethical issues
within organizations
governance is reported to be the biggest
enterprise requirement in ai in 2020
not only will enterprises embrace
governance we can expect increasing
legislation
potential regulatory issues and
consumers will begin to judge and select
organizations based on these policies
gartner reports that as consumers become
more aware and savvy about how
organizations are using their data and
organizations are using
increasing amounts of ai and ml to drive
business decisions
enterprises must embrace ideas like
explainable ai
and transparent data policies for both
ethical
and business reasons customers will
begin to judge
and select organizations based on these
policies
by 2020 gartner expects companies that
are
digitally trustworthy will generate 20
more online profit than those who are
not
this all fits into our belief at google
that responsible ai
equals successful ai we recognize that
the decisions we make
and the way we develop technology will
have a lasting impact
the efficiency gains and competitive
advantage are only going to be fully
realized
in a world where ai is responsibly
developed and trusted by end users
if anywhere trust gets broken we will
see ai getting pulled back
so to us responsible ai really leads
to successful ai
to build responsible ai into our dna
we begin asking ourselves a few
questions
this is rooted in the idea that people
and businesses with the best of
intentions
can potentially cause unintended harm
and we need to understand the risks and
build out
processes to avoid those outcomes
for us at google as you might relate we
feel an immense responsibility to
develop systems
to answer these critical questions and
build in the proper principles
practices and programs in support of
responsible ai development
to ensure that the ai we build and
enable for the world
is successful while we've come a long
way
this work is never finished it is far
from perfected
and we approach this work from a humble
place
we are constantly iterating and
assessing our work and progress
but don't pretend to have all of the
answers
our goal today is to share with you how
we've approached building responsibility
in by design
into our products but more importantly
our organization
to support the necessary inquiry
deliberation
and culture to build products aligned
with our values
we'll focus mainly on google cloud
because that's where we sit and because
it's arguably
one of the more complex areas to align
we have a range of general purpose
purpose tools
like auto mls and apis all the way to
solutions that go
much farther up the stack like contact
center ai
the way these technologies can be used
can be quite varied and hard to predict
which makes it a good place to discuss
putting principles
into practice what grounds our approach
to responsible ai at google are our ai
principles
ethical ai responsible ai and all of the
associated terms
can feel amorphous or nebulous how do
you begin to wrangle
all of the often contradictory ethical
theories
and critical components of ai
responsibility
into a systematic way to apply them to
your development
for us as for many organizations now
we found that the most important first
step
was developing our company-wide ai
principles
in the summer of 2017.
so in 2018 we published our ai
principles
these are not just a marketing campaign
for us
they are the constitution we use to
build our ai products
conduct research and draft our policies
our set of ai principles has been one of
the most important things we have
implemented
they keep us motivated by a common
purpose
succinctly communicate our values in
developing advanced technology for the
world
and ensure that the way we use
artificial intelligence
is in the best interest of humanity we
believe that
organizations and communities flourish
best when in addition to our own
personal ethical values there are also
shared ethical commitments
within the community that each person
can play a part in fulfilling
so that our work is more about doing
something good
together not doing whatever we privately
think
is best and just assuming or hoping
that others values and choices will
magically mirror
our own but
as we know a plan on paper
like these principles and practices are
only effective if they're
operationalized
looking at a list of principles like
ours can be hard
to incorporate into our day-to-day work
as we deal with detailed engagements
of our products what remains true
is that our ai principles aren't magic
they don't immediately answer
all of our questions on how to move
forward they don't relinquish us
from having hard conversations they are
a starting point in establishing
what we stand for and what we can agree
to build toward
the work that has ensured ensued beyond
the publication of the principles
has been to interpret and apply them in
practice
at the end of the day if something goes
wrong with the technology
and you have principles like ours and
you can't prove what you did
to prevent that then that is a terrible
outcome we realized
very quickly that in order to be true to
the principles
we needed to develop internal governance
processes
that put our principles into practice in
a systematic
and repeatable way this includes
building
responsible ai governance capacity in
the form of
product and customer deal review
committees
educational programs a partner program
and trainings
and how we consult and work with our
customers
we'll touch on each of these beginning
with google's ai review processes the
original hope was that the principles
would be a decision guide
but in reality they can't because the
company has such
a wide variety of the ways it uses ai
the reality is that you can take any
baseline technology
and it can be beneficial when used in
one way
and harmful in another so governing ai
is not only about the technology but
it's the combination
of the technology the use case the
training data
the societal context in which it
operates
and how it's deployed in production
there's no world
where blanket statements can hold water
if you're going to align
the principles and it requires that
people in the organization
are committed to the complexity
so we've built a google-wide ecosystem
around
how we operationalize we have a central
google function that consists of a
senior executive council
which is supported by a responsible
innovation team that team is chartered
with helping
teams around google in every product
area
learn to operationalize the principles
for themselves
when we in cloud initially thought about
how to begin putting our ai principles
into practice
and this happened before the principles
were published
our first instinct like many uh
is that we all all we had to do was
create a big decision tree
and a checklist for what's okay and
what's not
based on the principles we established
our ai principles are intentionally
broad
and google is a let a thousand flowers
bloom kind of place
and we have so much breadth in the
various product offerings that it would
be
impossible to have a checklist or
decision tree at the level of detail
that everyone would agree with
and i guarantee you that's the case for
you as well
checklists feel comforting but in
practice
have been ineffective at addressing
governance processes
for such nascent technologies in order
to provide
rigorous evaluations but flexibly allow
for the new technologies to take shape
in google cloud we've created two
separate review bodies that are
connected
but purposefully distinct the first
review body covers
early stage customer engagements where
we are
engaging in custom ai or advanced
technology with the customer or partner
this group is a decision making group
and it is very high throughput and its
intention
is to very quickly give an answer to the
field team
as to whether a project can move forward
is not aligned with the principles and
won't move forward
or if it will move forward with some
conditions
we've seen a range of those decisions
over the two plus years that we've been
doing this
the next half of the process is how we
build
and develop our products when it comes
to the ai products we develop at google
we undertake rigorous and deep ethical
analyses risk and opportunity
assessments
across each principle and we create
alignment proposals
that we bring to those reviews where we
often have
very uncomfortable but extraordinarily
inspiring conversations
with a healthy product pipeline we aim
for in-depth reviews
every two weeks relatively early on
in the product development life cycle
which is essential
in advance of the review meeting a
member of the team
takes on the task of doing an initial
evaluation of the product
working hand in hand with the technical
teams to understand the product
in depth in order to assess the
principal's implications
and recommend mitigations to build into
the plans for the product
this document serves as the basis
for the discussion come review time this
meeting of the minds
is one of the most important steps
in any principles evaluation to allow us
to do two things
issue spot as a team and come to
outcomes and paths forward for products
that are not just good in theory but are
able to be
actualized in practice over time
these conversations have been effective
at normalizing conversations
about risky technology and potentially
adverse outcomes
that we can then prevent the next
question i'm sure you're wondering
is what do those paths forward look like
the path forward can
look like a lot of different things it
can be that we more
narrowly scope the purpose of the
technology in some cases this can mean
we make a decision
not to launch a product as a general
purpose api
or without an allow list as you may have
seen
we decided in 2018 that we wouldn't make
facial recognition available as a
general purpose api
even though the technology exists we
won't make it available
for anyone to use and we found a path
forward
for the technology by scoping it to a
narrow celebrity recognition offering
which we'll talk about in a bit other
mitigations
can look like identifying educational
materials or
best practices to package up with a
product and launch it
this has taken the shape of launching
the product with the associated
model card a project we took on to
organize the essential facts of a
machine learning model
in a structured way or launching more
specific
implementation guides like our inclusive
ml guide
embedded in our product uis from there
we create an alignment plan with the
mitigations discussed in the meeting
which then goes through sign off by our
product
and engineering leadership it's key to
note that not all paths forward
involve tech solutions or fixes because
ethics problems are not always the
result
of technology lapses but are actually
more a product of the societal context
in which it's to being deployed and how
it's used
as intended over time through this
review process
we identify patterns similar to
case law where we are creating a growing
set
of precedents and best practices on
sensitive topics to inform decisions
and drive consistency on whether a new
product
can go ahead and with what mitigations
there's no one size fits all approach
flexibility is important and it's not
just a point in time as that societal
context changes
then we have to respond differently as
we make our decisions going forward
here are some of the imperatives and
challenges we've learned over those past
two years one thing that i really want
to stress
is the importance of a diverse review
committee
members are intentionally multi-level we
have
folks who are just starting their
careers out of college all
the way up through vps we're drawing on
a range of
experts from a diversity of backgrounds
both technical and non-technical
multiple team members including myself
have deep social science
and philosophy and ethics backgrounds
and we are really intending to be
cross-functional
across every role that exists at google
for the most part
and that we are not just drawing from
people within cloud
but that we are drawing from expertise
across
google for each review
we also seek out additional expertise
whether that be on issues of machine
learning fairness and robustness
or ethical ai or a particular
use case or technology or domain or
industry we're really lucky that at
google we have
a lot of that expertise in-house and
when we don't have it in our walls
we seek it externally one of the other
most
important things we did in the beginning
is we had the great
opportunity to hire a visiting
researcher
shannon ballard who was a tech ethicist
and world-renowned and she worked with
us to help
us build this process and engage in our
reviews in a way that
was incredibly useful for us
so what we've learned we've learned that
constitutions
like our ai principles require
interpretation
predicting misuse helps develop
guardrails
this requires us to imagine what if and
explore all the possible scenarios and
areas of misuse
in order to develop a comprehensive set
of guardrails
our principles aren't magic they don't
answer the tough questions
they're a framework for those
conversations deliberation
and healthy disagreement is key we do
not hold our team
as an ivory tower full of moral heroes
but
working collaboratively within our
technical teams to service potential
issues
and remediate them together ethical ai
is not only about the extremes and it's
not always
about ai for social good and it
shouldn't be
every ai product regardless of how
innocuous
it may seem should be put through
principles
evaluations
here are some of the trainings we offer
googlers to build responsibly ai
into our culture and equip teams with
the tools
and knowledge to insert responsible ai
into their day-to-day work
some of these are available externally
as well
our aim is to collect connect and
collaborate with partners
across the industry we want to share our
learnings
learn hear fresh and varied perspectives
and advance our collective thinking when
it comes to
responsible ai
the final way in which we put our
principles into practice
is through a growing set of tools
responsible ai tools and frameworks are
becoming an increasingly
important and effective way to explain
and understand our ai models
tools get at the questions how do i
understand the predictions made by ai
how do i know if my data or
model or outcomes have unfair bias and
how do i know what is influencing my
model's predictions
building tools and infrastructure to
evaluate and improve concerns at scale
today we'll touch on four tools we offer
that get at some of the main concerns
facing ai today
fairness indicators what-if tool model
cards
and explainable ai
we often get asked about de-biasing
models
and how we at google think about ml
fairness
broadly speaking there is no standard
definition of fairness
whether decisions are being made by
humans or machines
identifying appropriate fairness
criteria for a system
requires accounting for user experience
cultural social historical political
legal and ethical considerations several
of which
may have trade-offs i also want to
stress
that there is no future in which we will
be able to say
in my opinion that we have achieved
fairness
that we can say we're done with this
work and we can move on
this is something that we engage in for
the long term
and we are always learning more and
evolving
and we'll show you some examples of that
in a bit
so why does google care about these
problems well
our users are diverse and it's important
that we provide an experience that works
equally well
across all of our users the good news is
that we have the power to approach these
problems differently
and to create technology that is fairer
and
more inclusive for more people we'll
start with an overview of what that
means
and i should also say that this is an
area we are still learning about
and always will be addressing fairness
and ai
is an active area of research at google
and beyond
from fostering a diverse workforce that
embodies critical knowledge
from training models to remove and
correct problematic biases
knowing that there is no standard
definition of fairness
presents both an opportunity and a
challenge
one thing that i also think is really
important
that we've built into our review process
is a clear recognition
that we may not in our group have the
appropriate
lived experience that can help inform
how we build a product
we'll show you some examples of this in
a bit
but it's important that we recognize and
that i recognize
and stress for our team that we are
coming from a place
of great privilege and to honor that as
much
as we can this requires creating a space
that is rich with psychological safety
and i cannot stress enough the
importance of doing that work
an important step on this path is
acknowledging that humans are at the
center of technology design
in addition to being impacted by it and
humans have
not always made product design decisions
that
are in line with the needs of everyone
until 2011
automobile manufacturers were not
required
to use crash test dummies that
represented
female bodies as a result women
were 47 more likely to be seriously
injured in a car accident
than men
band-aids have long been manufactured in
a single
color a soft pink my skin tone
in this tweet you see the personal
experience of an individual using a
band-aid that
matches his skin tone for the first time
i will never forget i had a third grade
assembly
where somebody came a father of one of
my classmates
and told us pointed out that band-aids
were made
for white skin tones sober crayons
so were hosiery that was what the nude
color was
and once you know this you can't
unsee it it changes you forever and this
is why
surfacing these issues is so important
a product that's designed and intended
for widespread use
shouldn't fail for an individual because
of something they can't
change about themselves products and
technology
should work for everyone
the choices made in those two examples
reinforce the importance of being
thoughtful about technology design
and the impact it might have on humans
as in the case with those two examples
humans are at the center of machine
learning development and fairness
concerns
can easily become embedded into ai
product design decisions
so how can we approach technologies
to make them more inclusive and fair
unfairness can enter into the system
at any point in the ml pipeline here
from data collection
and handling to model training to end
use
in this typical view of an ml pipeline
you collect data
you label the data you train the model
using certain objectives
the data is packaged and put into a
product and users see the effect
and engage the way users engage informs
more data collection within that
pipeline
the way we sample data the way we label
it how the model was trained and whether
or not
the objective leaves out a particular
set of users
how it was packaged and what kinds of
unconscious biases
our users bring at engagement and how
that affects
how they behave and thus how we collect
more data can all work together
to create unfair biased systems
rarely can you identify a single cause
of
or a single solution to these problems
far more often various causes interact
in ml systems to produce problematic
outcomes
and a range of solutions is needed the
work
of ml fairness is to disentangle these
root causes and interactions
and find ways forward what's important
is getting clear on the questions we
need to answer
there are a smattering of questions that
can be used
to guide your fairness work across the
pipeline
everything from upfront product decision
which is often
underspecified in a lot of cases really
defining the problem
is all the way to identifying if and
when
a model isn't behaving correctly we want
to know
why did the model fail is the model
trustworthy
what are the limitations we found these
questions
to be helpful in guiding our
investigations underlying
all of this is making sure the workforce
is inclusive
the best way to make sure as we that we
as
teams are equipped is to have a diverse
workforce having these conversations
back to our pipeline at each stage of
this life cycle
we have identified tools best practices
and frameworks
to help ml practitioners in their
efforts to build responsible ai
at the start we are looking at problem
definitions and the resources
we have when we initially qualitatively
speak to what we want to accomplish
but when we talk about fairness some of
the tools and resources we have found
valuable here
for fairness are the stages at the end
of the ml life cycle where we've really
focused
in terms of tool development and
transparency frameworks
is the evaluation and in the evaluation
and monitoring stages
i want to move now into some case
studies to show you some examples
of how this work has gone for us
and what we've done both in the process
of launching products
and evaluating problems when they arose
the first case study outlines our
approach in cloud
to facial recognition and how we got to
this approach
through our ai principles and the review
processes we've put into place
to operationalize them
i'm going to start with the outcome of
our in-depth review
of enterprise spatial recognition
technology you can see here the headline
is the launch
of a tightly scoped api called celebrity
recognition
available to professional media and
entertainment customers
we launched this last fall you may
realize
that video is all but unsearchable
without expensive
and labor-intensive tagging processes
this makes it
really difficult for creators and
platforms
to organize their content and cater to
the increasing demand
for personalized experiences or even
really understand
what content they have so celebrity
recognition
is a pre-trained ai model which means
it's not customizable
that is able to spot thousands of
popular actors
and athletes from around the world based
on licensed images
this is cloud's first enterprise product
with facial recognition
so i want to talk a bit about the
history in early 2016
cloud leadership decided not to make
facial recognition
available as part of the cloud vision
api
offering despite it being one of the top
requests from customers
coming out of beta which was started the
year before
in 2017 facial recognition was
identified internally as a key concern
for potential unfair bias
in our definition of algorithmic
unfairness
which was written by our privacy and
security and now
responsible innovation and privacy
colleagues
the core definitional document for
google's machine learning fearless
fairness efforts we decided to take face
recognition
through the process we described earlier
in mid 2020 just recently we
welcomed the news that other technology
companies were limiting
or exiting their facial recognition
business
and this was thanks significantly to the
gender shades work
which really informed how this
technology can have
impact across a range of
unfair biases from skin tone to gender
as you know we decided not to make a
generally available
face recognition api available
because of our process back in 2018.
so what we did initially within cloud is
an in-depth review
of face recognition technology by both
our deal review
and our product review bodies as well as
the central google executive council
our own internal review processes
necessitated a broad look
at their research societal context and
complexities around facial recognition
going through these processes and this
was the second review
we ever did gave us the open forum and
the time to really think critically
about the challenges
and we realized that alone we couldn't
do this
so we sought help from third parties to
work with us
on both external benchmarking and
performance and we began
a human rights due diligence process
where we called on domain experts
and civil rights leaders and human
rights leaders that would allow us to
incorporate the perspectives
of impacted people just a reminder
of going back to that conversation about
how
our lived experience is not going to
help us inform the lives and
perspectives of
impacted people and so it was really
important that we did the work to
understand that
because the reality is everything we do
every product we launch every market we
enter does not
exist in a vacuum and in order for us to
make decisions
that are aligned with our ai principles
we have to take this into account
at every step technical analysis
alone is not enough because the reality
is that there is systematic societal
underrepresentation
in media of black and minoritized actors
and this needed to be the basis for our
evaluation
as a side note just with the analysis
that the gina davis institute did on
gender
which showed that women-led films made
16
more in the box office despite men being
both
seen and heard twice as much as women
on film you can see that films with
racially diverse co-leads
had created 60 percent more in gross
income for those films but were grossly
underrepresented in film more broadly
human rights due diligence became a core
part of what we needed to do
human rights are a basic code of conduct
for all human beings and we honor the
universal declaration
of human rights through the un and so
again we really wanted to seek
external voices to help us make this
assessment
and so we engaged in a process called a
human rights impact assessment
we did this through an organization
called bsr
and bsr stands for business for social
responsibility
and they helped us to really
significantly improve our product
offering
engaging with bsr validated many of
our already planned for alignment
opportunities
and we incorporated almost all of their
additional
suggestions across a range of aspects of
the product
their report is publicly available and i
encourage all of you to read it
all of this guidance and the reviews
informed where we needed to do
our testing and fairness analyses and it
revealed to us both where the solution
needed additional oversight
and validated the decision not to offer
a general purpose facial recognition api
so
in the coming slides i'm going to show
you a deep dive into the investigations
that then further informed the product
decisions we made
before launching so over
three separate fairness tests we found a
discrepancy
in our training data sets falling on
skin tone lines
in one of those tests it's the one on
the right the eastwood
v2 this was obviously very upsetting and
just like we saw
earlier in the presentation for many
organizations
this is where they would have stopped
and said
we are just not going to do this but
because we knew
that we wanted to evaluate this as
thoroughly as we could
we decided to take a deeper look the
first thing
we had to determine was if the skin tone
labels were accurate
the answer was sort of they were not
terribly accurate in categorizing medium
and darker skinned people
so based on the seminal work and the
findings of the gender shade study
we categorized skin tone into three
buckets using the dermatological
fitzpatrick skin type scale
which is an estimate of skin sensitivity
to uv radiation
going through labeling the skin tones
resulted in a smaller gap
in the errors especially for the medium
skin tones
but there was still a problem in errors
for the darker skin tones
so here are the results of that
relabeling 25
of the skin tone labels changed
categories and
it completely closed the performance gap
with the medium
female skin tone so that then led us
to the additional discrepancies what we
found
was that a very small subset of actors
and actresses
represented a significant proportion of
the total missed identifications in that
evaluation data set
and this was especially for the dark
skin tone groups
and especially for men so with that
knowledge
that a select few actors were
disproportionately affecting the error
rates in this data set
we looked at those actors with the
largest number of errors
and found that they had nearly a 100
false rejection rate because we had made
the decision
earlier not to do a general face
recognition api
but to take this carefully scoped
approach
we were actually able to go one by one
through the gallery and the test set to
determine what the problem
was so here's what we found
it was really three actors where our
celebrity gallery had images of those
actors
as adults while the eastwood training
set had videos of them
much younger all from the tv show family
matters
our model could not recognize the adult
actors
as the younger characters they had
played many years prior
in this instance for our celebrity
recognition model
we were able to correct that problem by
hand labeling which closed the gap
completely and that is what allowed us
to get comfort with launching this
product
but the answer here is not to say
that this was an instance of age of in
the images
because we took the time to look at the
larger landscape
and we know the issues of representation
in media
the fact that there's a discrepancy gave
us pause to think about
what might actually be happening here
this is an example of why this process
is so
important and these were some of the
headlines and in fact
this is the bsr report as well but
really
it's not about slow walking it's about
responsible development of ai which is
what leads to successful deployment of
ai
none of this exists outside of the
larger landscape we looked at initially
and it's because we started with that
understanding
we were prepared to address it and we
have to consider that
at every step ethical ai is not only
about the extremes and it's not always
about ai for social good
and it shouldn't be it's about being
part of
every use case where our job is to find
a path
through extremely complex and
intersecting
realities
this case study will show you how we
responded to two issues
with a generally available product which
was
our google cloud vision api
labeling is a common practice used to
classify images
and train machine learning models across
many applications
labeling is core to vision ai products
and in 2019
we identified an instance that violated
our ai principle
to avoid creating unfair bias
employees are our best source of
feedback and that is how we were able to
identify this
issue a googler ran an image
of themself in the api returning a
result
that misgendered them the cougar flagged
this to the cloud vision product team
which set forth an investigation into
this issue
through the review and assessment of
this escalation
it was important to put this issue in
the context
of the user by identifying the cause
and effect this could have gender
misidentification
like what happened to this googler
occurs because a person's gender
cannot be inferred based on their
physical appearance
by a human or model their outward
appearance that the model uses
is not a determining factor when
assessing gender
and the impact of doing so exacerbates
or creates unfair assumptions that
restrict
or harm those who do not look
stereotypically male
or female or who are a gender
non-conforming person
the steps to evaluate an escalation are
not always the same
some require in-depth product testing
industry expertise third-party
assessments
and so on having identified the issue
the potentially harmful impact to users
we formulated a go-forward plan
reinforcing google's commitment to build
products for everyone
we made the decision that a person's
gender cannot be inferred by appearance
and attempting to do so could perpetuate
unfair bias
removing man and woman labels from the
cloud vision api
and replacing them with a non-gender
label such as person
is the the act we took
through this process we learned a couple
key things that altered our approach to
gendered
labeled data there are often more
targeted signals
to attribute to a person that provide
more valuable information to a customer
taking retail stores as an example who
might historically analyze foot traffic
with demographic information
a more targeted labeling could be a
person's fashion sense
to analyze foot traffic and cater their
inventory to those fashion types
we also came to the conclusion that when
it comes to general tools
where we do not have control over
customer use cases
to take a cautious approach with
capabilities and functionality
and build targeted solutions where we
have a hand
in the development and use case
the second example is the result of an
escalation of our vision api
earlier this year 2020 and it shows how
important an understanding of the
societal context
is in which our products exist
here is the escalation you can see here
the image
with a black person and a handheld
thermometer
returned a label for firearm and an
asian person
holding a handheld thermometer returned
a label for
electronic devices this was brought to
our attention
through the tweet you see here on the
left
what happened next was someone taking
the photo of the black man holding a
thermometer gun
and manipulating the image to make the
skin appear to be lighter
as you can see this changed the label
from gun
to tulle which is a deeply distressing
result it is critical
to recognize why a result like this can
create
increased harm the statistics here
highlight some of the societal context
in which this lives
any robust evaluation of this escalation
cannot separate this reality of racial
justice
racial violence and systemic racism from
the technical
analysis so what did we do
our investigations led us across
multiple teams and you can see here the
results of some of those
changing the skin tone in the first
example through some of our counter
factual testing
does change the api's prediction but
what we found was that gun
was still a top five label response for
all three images
in skin tones although the api demo
didn't surface this result
we used our own explanations ai to look
at saliency mapping
saliency maps for the third hand images
show that the attributes
cluster predominantly on the thermometer
for all three images with some bleed
into the upper fingers of the hand
for the darker and medium skin tone
hands
when we went into our counterfactual
testing further
you could see that a change of color of
the thermometer gun
in the original image also caused the
gun label to disappear
we then did stability testing and in
this case
the image appears very sensitive to
image cropping
even minor variations make that gun
label
disappear we also looked at our training
data
we don't have many images of handheld
infrared thermometers
and so this was a gap as it's a newer
product in our own
image database and it's not necessarily
incorrect
that this be labeled gum as they are
called thermometer guns
but if that's the case then they should
be labeled that way unilaterally
we found that many images were
mislabeled gone
including things like cameras for
example
this example represents an all hands on
deck
process that required a humble approach
and
thoughtful action to remedy by
conducting a detailed assessment of the
root cause of this
issue we were able to understand that
model accuracy and stability were key
drivers
and by adjusting the confidence
threshold to more precisely return
labels when a firearm is present
we could greatly decrease the chance of
this happening in the future
this example showed us again that we
have to do the work
to put the harm in context in order
to truly assess the extent of it
it isn't enough to say that this was
only about model accuracy and stability
because this result was harmful and it
exists
in a world of much larger harms
that we have to think about when we
address the problem
what this taught us through experience
was that none
of the evaluations we do exist outside
of the large landscape
and that context in which they lived and
that's the case
for every analysis we undertake for
every product we launch
for every decision we make about how to
best respect
our users the opportunities and each
other
thank you so much for joining us today i
hope you've enjoyed
this conversation and i look forward to
many more
in the future